vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins
dulong vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un sommet historique en terrain neutre
vladimir poutine et joe biden se
rencontrent aujourd'hui à genève un face
à face inédit pour tenter d'apaiser les
tensions depuis l'investiture du
président américain les relations entre
moscou et washington sont au plus bas
les attentes sont nombreuses on va
suivre ensemble en direct cet entretien
inédit avec nos envoyés spéciaux sur
place
et nos invités en plateau bonjour à tous
et bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez en
direct pour cette édition spéciale
consacrée au sommet de genève entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden une
rencontre qui sera scruté dans le monde
entier puisque les deux dirigeants les
plus puissantes de la planète vont se
retrouver dans moins d'une heure à
genève la suisse dernière étape de la
première tournée européenne du président
américain
son avion air force one s'est posé hier
dans l'après midi à l'aéroport de genève
en provenance de bruxelles le président
russe lui doit arriver dans peu de temps
un sommet sur fond de tensions
diplomatiques alors comment va se
dérouler cette première rencontre entre
les deux chefs d'état on retrouve en
direct de genève nos envoyés spéciaux
olivier de kairon fleck est fan numéro
messieurs bonjour olivier tout d'abord
on vit ensemble cette édition spéciale
en direct de genève vous êtes tous deux
sur place est ce que on en sait un peu
plus sur le programme de la journée
oui bonjour doha alors effectivement ici
tout est en place pour accueillir ce
sommet entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine le président russe qui doit
arriver maintenant dans un peu moins de
30 minutes à l'aéroport international de
genève
et puis une demi heure plus tard et bien
ce sera la grande rencontre qui débutera
avec la traditionnelle poignée de main
entre les deux hommes avant une réunion
de travail un qui va durer entre quatre
et cinq heures selon nos premières
informations alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que les deux hommes aient bien ils
ne seront pas en face à face ils ne
seront pas tous les deux ils sont
accompagnés
une délégation du côté russe et bien le
ministre des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov lui est arrivé hier à genève et
il accompagnera le président russe
vladimir poutine pour une première
rencontre joe biden lui sera
raccompagner dans tony blinken le chef
de la diplomatie et puis après cet
après-midi de négociation et bien il n'y
aura pas de conférence de presse commune
c'était une volonté de l'administration
américaine ce sera à vladimir poutine
qui à 18 heures c'est ce qui est prévu
en tout cas pour le moment mais ça peut
évoluer et bien donnera une conférence
de presse
et puis joe biden lui prendra la parole
à l'issue alors cette rencontre et bien
elle a lieu à la villa lagrange à
quelques centaines de mètres un dc donc
tout et tout est verrouillé ici un plus
de piétons aux alentours plus de
véhicules non plus on va pouvoir
d'ailleurs tout de suite retrouvé notre
envoyé spécial antoine claireaux il se
trouve au coeur de l'événement il va
pouvoir suivre pour nous cette rencontre
au plus près antoine est ce que vous
nous entendez vous êtes donc à la ville
à la grange
quelle est l'atmosphère sur place
racontez nous et bien la tension vient
de monter d'un cran car il ya tout juste
quelques minutes trois quatre minutes
pas plus une partie de la délégation
russe est d'ores et déjà arrivé j'ai pu
reconnaître
dimitri peskov ont encore plusieurs
diplomates de la mission permanente de
la russie auprès de l'office des nations
unies ici à genève sinon vous l'avez
évoqué rapidement à genève c c'est un
camp retranché on y circule plus les
piétons ne sont pas autorisés à circuler
dans le centre ville et il y a
littéralement des forces de l'ordre à
chaque à chaque coin de rue dorénavant
ce sont les axes que vont emprunter les
respectivement joe biden et vladimir
poutine qui sont particulièrement
scrutés par les forces de l'ordre dans
le centre ville de genève
alors antoine je crois que vous avez eu
le privilège de rentrer à l'intérieur de
la villa lagrange là où les deux hommes
vont se parler mais tout à fait hier
dans l'après midi nous avons eu un accès
privilégié à l'intérieur de cette
magnifique villa nous avons pu accéder
en particulier à deux pièces qui vont
être très importantes tout d'abord la
bibliothèque de la villa où vont pouvoir
se rencontrer vladimir poutine et joe
biden dans un format restreint avec une
partie restreinte de leur délégation est
également une autre pièce plus vaste où
ils pourront se rencontrer avec leurs
délégations dans un format plus large et
c'est d'ailleurs dans cette pièce que
risque de se passer
la plupart des discussions la plupart
des discussions d'aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup antoine alors bien
évidemment cette fameuse poignée de main
tant attendu c'est avec vous qu'on va la
suivre elle est prévu je vous le disais
tout à l'heure aux alentours de 13
heures en attendant vladimir poutine lui
doit arriver dans un peu moins de 30
minutes sont maintenant alors ce n'est
pas la première fois que les deux hommes
vont se voir en chair et en os en 2011
weiden alors vice-président de barack
obama s'était rendu au kremlin mais
c'était un tout autre contexte un deux
puis il est rentré à la maison blanche
alors il s'est déjà entretenu mais
uniquement par téléphone avec son
homologue russe depuis janvier dernier
et vous le savez un depuis les tensions
sont croissantes alors de nombreux
dossiers qui cristallise les tensions et
bien ils vont être abordés puisque les
sujets ont été définies en amont de
cette rencontre
on sait notamment que les deux hommes
vont parler du sujet de l'ukraine un
sujet épineux mais également de la
situation au moyen-orient plus
précisément la syrie l'irak ou encore la
libye il y aura la situation au karabagh
dans la péninsule coréenne également qui
seront évoqués et puis la sphère navalni
elle aussi qui a cristallisé fortement
les tensions ces derniers mois ou encore
le dossier biélorusse eh bien il est
prévu également que les deux hommes
l'évoquent doha alors on va pouvoir
retourner à paris en attendant de vous
faire vivre en direct ici
l'arrivée du président russe puisque
doha vous êtes avec un invité un pour
décrypter les enjeux de cette rencontre
exactement olivier merci en tout cas
pour toutes ces précisions va tout de
suite continué à parler de ce sommet
russo américain avec notre invité jean
eric branaa historien et spécialiste des
états unis bonjour jean eric branaa
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin tous les regards sont donc
tournés vers genève ce matin
joe biden qui rencontre vladimir poutine
concrètement que faut-il attendre de ce
sommet il faut attendre d'amour ce qu'on
a sous les yeux c'est à dire qu'il ya
une rencontre est en réalité quand les
relations sont aussi bas qu elles
peuvent être aujourd'hui en soldes pays
de chaque côté on dit que ça fait 30 ans
que ça n'a pas été aussi catastrophique
le fait de se parler et déjà une bonne
chose c'est la stratégie que joy ride
d'avenir d'avant dit qu'il est devenu
président il avait beaucoup développée
pendant sa campagne
n'oublions pas que c'est un diplomate et
il considère que la diplomatie c'est
parler avec les gens qui sont le plus
éloignés de nous donc là on ou
difficilement faire plus éloignées
peut-être avec la chine mais ce sera
l'étape suivante
alors on fait que à l'origine de cette
invitation de cette rencontre c'est un
job hayden quelles sont vraiment les
motifs et les objectifs du président
américain
ils sont nombreux je veux dire c'est
d'abord de se parler donc de calmer les
tensions qu'il peut y avoir dans le
bourg de dans le but de stabiliser les
relations entre les etats-unis et la
chine le fait que ça ne s'embrasse pas
et c'est vrai que dans les relations
difficiles c'est assez facile que ça
s'embrase et puis surtout on a derrière
en arrière-plan la chine qui apparaît
puisque c'est là le vrai but de joe
biden il s'agit de faire en sorte que
les russes ne se sentent pas totalement
rejetée par la communauté internationale
surtout qu'avec 2 vient de faire un vrai
numéro
g7 et à l'otan en réunissant le bloc des
diplomaties comme il vient de le dire
donc de ne pas renvoyer par effet
contraire les russes dans les bras des
chinois donc on ouvre une porte et on
verra ce que donnera cette porte à la
fin cette porte ouverte mais en réalité
c'est de pouvoir montrer qu'il ya quand
même une possibilité de se raccrocher ne
se rapprocher sur certains dossiers
sensibles ou difficile alors on a quand
même l'impression que le scepticisme est
de mise en tout cas du côté américain on
sait que la maison blanche a lancé un
message qui est plutôt clair si vous
attendez des retombées concrètes de ce
sommet vous pouvez attendre longtemps
comment est-ce qu'il faut justement
interprété cet avertissement on va dire
alors je crois que le scepticisme est
fort des deux côtés en réalité on vient
de le dire ça fait 30 ans que les
relations sont difficiles entre la
russie et les etats unis elle était
encore plus difficile avant du temps où
où c'était l'union soviétique et qu'il
ya eu une guerre froide pour autant moi
je me méfierais quand même cette
déclaration dans lequel on dit qu'il
faut rien à temps parce qu'il ya quand
même des sujets sur lesquels les deux
hommes peuvent se rapprocher en
particulier la protection des
populations en syrie sur lesquels byden
compte beaucoup quand même sur poutine
et puis le climat qui parle de la vraie
grande question du mandat de joe biden
et et la fixer de nouveaux objectifs
c'était le 22 avril au moment du sommet
de la terre aux états unis à ce moment
là qu'il avait répondu par l'affirmative
en disant qu'il allait lui aussi baissé
les gaz à effet de serre dans son pays
de façon drastique là-dessus mais je
pense qu'on pourrait attendre qu'il
sorte quelque chose de ceux de cette
rencontre ce qui voudrait dire qu'on
sortirait avec un bilan positif même si
sur le reste c'est vrai que ça va être
très difficile de faire bouger les
lignes en une seule fois mais encore une
fois c'est une dialogue renoux et c'est
ce qu'on va retenir
alors faut-il attendre de l'apaisement
c'est en tout cas la grande question à
laquelle peut être on aura une réponse
cet après midi c'est tout l'enjeu
d'ailleurs de ce sommet russo américain
car après avoir réaffirmé sa volonté de
redonner de la vigueur aux relations
transatlantique joe biden a affiché son
intention d'adresser un message clair
vladimir poutine on sait que le chef du
kremlin a lui aussi donné le ton il a
répondu ces derniers jours déclaration
de son homologue américain les
précisions de françois dix critiques
monsieur le président êtes-vous un tueur
écouté durant ma carrière je me suis
habitué aux attaques venant de tous les
côtés pour de nombreuses raisons à des
attaques de différentes qualités et
finesse rien de cela ne m'étonne les
personnes avec qui nous coopérons et
nous disputons sur la scène
internationale et nous même ne sommes
pas de jeunes mariés nous ne nous
leurrons pas amour et amitié pour
l'éternité
nous sommes des partenaires et sous
certains angles
nous sommes rivaux voilà qui devrait
détendre zobaï de vladimir poutine n'est
donc pas un tueur lors d'une interview
en mars dernier pour la télévision
américaine soit deux mois après son
investiture s'est pourtant bien en ces
termes qu'il qualifie le président russe
une accusation soudaine le lendemain
vladimir poutine lui répond non sans
ironie vous savez je me souviens pendant
l'enfance lorsque l'on se disputer dans
la cour on disait c'est celui qui dit
qui y est
et ce n'est pas par hasard ce n'est pas
une expression utilisée seulement par
les enfants ou une blague le sens
psychologique est très profond nous
voyons toujours en autrui des qualités
qui nous sont propres et nous pensons
qu'il est tout comme nous
je connais mais derrière l'humour la
mise au point ce voeu cinglante dans la
foulée moscou décide de rappeler
l'ambassadeur russe en poste aux états
unis une première depuis 1998
nouvel épisode le 15 avril lorsque joe
biden annonce une série de sanctions
financières contre moscou et l'expulsion
de deux diplomates russes des sanctions
tout en proposant une rencontre vladimir
poutine le moment de la désescalade est
venu nous devons aller de l'avant au
moyen d'un dialogue réfléchi et d'un
processus diplomatique
ma ligne directrice est la suivante
lorsque les états unis ont intérêt à
travailler avec la russie nous devons le
faire et nous le ferons lorsque la
russie cherchent à porter atteinte aux
intérêts des états unis nous répondrons
le président russe laisse ses porte
paroles répondre le kremlin assurant que
les dates concrètes sont à l'étude
ce sera donc le séjour je vais
rencontrer le président poutine dans
deux semaines à genève
et je dirai clairement que nous ne
resterons pas les bras croisés pendant
qu'il viole ses droits humains vladimir
poutine est donc prévenu joe biden sera
ferme
pas de quoi vraiment inquiéter moscou
qui ne se fait pas d'illusion sur le
site des décisions amenant des
changements fondamentaux
après tout un aigle n'a jamais fait peur
à un ours
alors j'en dirais que branagh historien
et spécialiste des états unis vous êtes
toujours avec nous en direct pour
décrypter ce
historique à votre avis la balle est
dans quel camp ce matin j'ai envie de
vous dire que laval est au centre
c'est assez clair on commence un nouveau
match il s'agit de tourner la page
trimpe dans laquelle les états unis et
là je parle du personnel politique
américain était très inquiet que les
intérêts américains ne soient pas
défendu auprès de poutine quand il ya eu
cette rencontre en 2017 en particulier
plus globalement on sait qu'avec jo
maiden c'est la fermeté qu'il n'y a
aucune qu'il n'y aura pas de transit
jans vis-à-vis de poutine mais en même
temps c'est vrai que comme je le disais
la porte est ouverte
alors le rapport de force entre les deux
n'est pas le même si c'était là plutôt
porter votre question les états unis
sont évidemment bien plus en avance sur
un grand nombre de plans qu'ils soient
militaires stratégiques économiques et
mais en même temps la capacité de nuire
des russes est très forte
et puis il ya une donnée fondamentale
qui n'est pas comprise par les russes
alors tout petit problème de liaison
avec notre invité jean eric branaa alors
où vous avez sûrement vous êtes en ligne
voilà vous êtes avec nous jean eric
branaa on a eu un petit problème de
liaison donc on était en train de parler
de ce rapport on a l'impression que les
deux hommes souffle le chaud et le froid
le froid en même temps et vous me disais
que finalement pour l'instant la balle
est ton centre que le rapport de force
n'est pas le même non j'étais en train
de dire que les russes effectivement ne
donnons pas la même force que les états
unis sur un certain nombre de dossiers
qu'ils soient stratégiques militaires
économiques
et puis il ya les en compréhension de
part et d'autre notamment sur cette
question des droits de l'homme si chère
à joe biden qui a dévoué sa vie et c'est
vrai que sa vision n'est vraiment pas
celle de poutine lors c'est là dessus
aussi que ça risque d'accrocher pas mal
et là dessus on peut pas attendre
aujourd'hui des avancées mais par contre
il donne va être très ferme cette
question et là il s'adressera à la fois
à ses convictions mais également à son
électorat électorat américain de façon
plus générale parce que c'est une
question qui compte beaucoup dans ce
pays et justement comment cette
rencontre est elle perçue aux états unis
pays que vous connaissez bien
allez encore une fois il le fait que ce
soit maiden rassure plutôt tout le monde
parce qu'abidal a toujours été ferme
vis-à-vis de poutine a rappelé dans le
reportage qui l'a traité de tueur au
début de son mandat
mais en 2011 il avait déjà regarder dans
le blanc des yeux comme qui dit lui-même
en lui disons je vois que vous n'avez
pas d'amis
autrement dit vous êtes le diable on vas
y on était encore plus haut dans la
rhétorique agressive si on peut le dire
ainsi mais ça montre aussi que maiden
porte une certaine auto d'auxi vis-à-vis
de la russie qui portent de par son âge
il a traversé la guerre froide il a donc
les mêmes idées que les américains de
son âge qui ont toujours vu les russes
comme l'ennemi et c'est vrai que cette
complexité qui lie à entre les deux pays
bas et donne l'incarnent totalement donc
aucune crainte dans son pays vis-à-vis
de ce qui peut se passer entre tutti
n'est pas et donne ils savent bien que
leurs intérêts seront défendus je parle
encore une fois vous hésitez alors il ya
énormément de points de divergence mais
at il tout de même des points de
convergence entre les deux grandes
puissances mondiales
oui les bois de l'argent ce sont son
four membres eux c'est vrai le climat
est certainement comme je dis d'ailleurs
le point de convergence le plus évident
on va aussi beaucoup discuté des
questions de cyber qu'elle soit
cybersécurité ou au cyber espace là
dessus peut-être qu'il faut les points
de vue pourraient se rapprocher alors
c'est vrai que les américains accusent
beaucoup les russes d'ingérence
notamment et les et de l'est de hacking
mai mais comme les russes on voit la
balle en expliquant qu'ils ne sont pour
rien et qui seraient aussi victimes
peut-être que la question de la sécurité
cyber pourrait arriver à trouver une fin
plus heureuse on va dire en tout cas une
voix de travail qui pourraient être
intéressés et justement fait joe biden a
promis de dire sans détour quelles sont
ces lignes rouges à vladimir poutine
dans un entretien récemment à la chaîne
américaine nbc le chef du kremlin a
déclaré espérer que le président
démocrate se montre moins impulsif que
son prédécesseur républicain
l'occasion également pour lui de
souligner combien donald trump était
selon lui un homme talentueux on sait
que les relations étaient différentes
avec donald trump avec joe biden je vous
propose de faire un petit retour en
arrière
le 16 juillet 2018 précisément le sommet
d'helsinki le premier tête à tête entre
vladimir poutine et donald trump un
sujet signé y militent gâche la volonté
d'un rapprochement russo américain aura
marqué ce sommet d'helsinki
alors que nombre d'observateurs
s'attendaient à une rencontre sous haute
tension
ces pourparlers avait été décrit comme
très réussi et utile par vladimir
poutine
les pourparlers avec le président
américain donald trump se sont déroulées
dans une atmosphère ouverte et
professionnels je les considère comme
très réussie utile nous avons examiné
l'état actuel et la perspective des
relations russo américaines ainsi que
les questions clé de l'agenda
international
les désaccords entre nos deux pays sont
bien connus et le président poutine et
moi en avons longuement discuté
aujourd'hui
mais si nous voulons résoudre les
nombreux problèmes auxquels notre monde
est confronté
nous devons trouver des moyens de
coopérer afin de satisfaire nos intérêts
communs
parmi les sujets abordés la situation en
syrie
la crimée le nucléaire mais aussi les
accusations d'ingérence de la russie
dans l'élection présidentielle
américaine de novembre 2016 qui avait vu
la victoire de donald trump et sur ce
point
pendant la conférence de presse commune
donald trump avait fait une déclaration
suscitant un tollé au sein de la classe
politique américaine
le président poutine m'a dit que ce
n'est pas à la russie je vais vous dire
je ne vois aucune raison pour laquelle
ce serait la russie une remise en cause
des enquêtes des services de
renseignement américains critiqué dans
le camp démocrate comme dans celui du
président
le parti républicain dans toute
l'histoire de notre pays
les américains n'avaient jamais vu un
président des états unis soutenir un
adversaire de l'amérique comme donald
trump vient de soutenir le président
poutine
il n'ya pas moralement d'équivalence
entre les états unis et la russie qui
demeurent hostiles à nos idéaux et à nos
valeurs fondamentales
les etats unis doivent s'attacher à
demander des comptes à la russie et à
mettre fin des attaques ignobles contre
la démocratie
donald trump avait fini par revenir sur
ses propos
il avait aussi accusé ses détracteurs
d'être dérangés par sa bonne entente
avec vladimir poutine
leur sommet à d'ailleurs été marqué par
cette image
à l'issue de cette conférence de presse
commune vadimir poutine avait offert un
ballon de football à donald trump et
déclaré que la balle était dans son camp
là on risque pas d'avoir la même image
ce matin en tout cas pour l'instant on
sait qu'il n'y aura pas de conférence de
presse commune prévue après leurs
discussions
joe biden et vladimir poutine qui ont
préféré faire tout seul lors leur
conférence de presse justement comment
interpréter cette décision jean eric
kabera n'a écouté la conférence de
presse commune c'est quand tout va bien
en réalité rien allait bien entre les
deux pays et rien n'allait dans la
conférence de presse qui avait été
donnée par conjointement par donald
trump et l'admirent poutine par exemple
a dit m poutine avait parlé en premier
aux états unis on s'est demandé pourquoi
donc la préséance le protocole mais il
n'y a pas vraiment de raison ensuite le
la rencontre s'était fait dans le secret
le plus absolu et et poutine avait
commenté cette rencontre en expliquant
que tout s'était très bien passé qu'il
était très content des résultats
le fantasme s'était aussitôt envolés
bien entendu quelles étaient ses
résultats pourquoi qu'est ce qui avait
été discuté on n'en savait rien et est
annoncée toujours et aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs donc là dessus bien sûr
l'hostilité naturel des américains
vis-à-vis des russes avaient enflammé
les imaginations et a fait que beaucoup
d'erreurs ont été commises par
l'administration trotte dans cette
rencontre qui aurait dû être prises avec
des pincettes
et effectivement quand il a terminé en
mettant en cause ses propres services de
renseignement pour donner crédit à la
parole de celui qui est vécu comme
l'ennemi d'amérique
bien évidemment c'était la cerise sur le
gâteau et la classe politique américaine
c'était là aussi enflammé d'ailleurs
quelques mois plus tard le congrès
quelques mois quelques semaines plus
tard le congrès a voté des sanctions à
l'unanimité contre l'avis de donald
trump qui avait menacé de son veto qui
finalement ne l'avait pas posée puisque
le congrès était unanime contre lui est
donc levé tôt on voudrait été surmontée
mais là dessus on n'aura pas la même
chose avec du rider on aura avancé
dossier par dossier de façon pragmatique
on va discuter de dossiers urgents comme
le lean stark 3 qui devrait être
prolongée jusqu'à 2026 on va discuter de
la question des populations en syrie on
va discuter de l'afghanistan parce que
tu es l'iran d'israël
la crimée de navalni et les dossiers
seront à vous rendre les uns par uns et
chacun va faire un bar de son point de
vue ça sera déjà une première étape
c'est ce qu'on appelle se reparler elle
a un programme bien chargé des
discussions qui risque d'être longue en
tout cas merci beaucoup jean eric branaa
d'avoir été avec nous pour décrypter ce
matin ce sommet très attendu entre
vladimir poutine et djoubaye dun eric
branaa spécialiste des états unis merci
allez on va tout de suite prendre la
direction de genève pour retrouver nos
envoyés spéciaux sur place olivier de
kerentrech ça y est un tout est prêt
voilà on attend dans quelques minutes
l'arrivée du président russe vladimir
poutine
et oui doha dans quelques minutes
puisque nous voyons au loin un avion qui
semble arriver vers l'aéroport de genève
il semblerait que ce soit l'avion de
vladimir poutine
jordi demory qui est derrière la caméra
nous le montrera dès que possible mais
effectivement on le voit aux lois donc
vladimir poutine qui était attendu à
12h30 avant donc ce sommet qui doit
débuter à 13h d'ailleurs sur place à la
villa lagrange est bien le président 6
lui est déjà arrivé
guy parmelin qui se réjouit que la
suisse puisse renouer avec sa longue
tradition en matière d'accueil et de
médiation je vous le rappelle depuis
la suisse a le statut de pays neutre
alors justement à la ville à la grange
et bien antoine et claireaux notre
envoyé spécial est sur place
antoine vous confirmer à le président
suisse lui est bien arrivé il ya
quelques minutes un sur zone
où il a tout juste deux minutes le
convoi celui-ci arrivait donc 7,8
véhicule accompagné également de motos
de police et on a vu donc les
dignitaires suisse sortir de ces
véhicules dont le président de la
confédération suisse
guy parmelin qui aura la charge
d'accueillir tour à tour vladimir
poutine puis joe biden ce sera sur les
coups de 13 heures environ il a
également une vingtaine de minutes
c'est une partie de la délégation russe
qui est arrivé avec entre autres dimitri
peskov ainsi que plusieurs diplomates
delà de la permanence russe auprès du
siège des nations unies de genève alors
que en ce moment même nous avons un
nouveau convoi qui arrive au niveau de
la ville à la grange cinq véhicules
cinq véhicules qui arrivent donc encore
une partie de la délégation suisse a
priori
voilà d'ailleurs la délégation suisse
qui est prête à la ville à la grange et
oui effectivement doha la délégation
suisse donc si elle est arrivée à la
ville à la grange et on voit en ce
moment même
l'avion du président russe vladimir
poutine en phase d'atterrissage à
l'aéroport d'international de jeu est de
genève donc une arrivée à 12h30
comme le programme le prévoyait alors un
vladimir poutine il faut le noter qui
sera accueilli par le président suisse à
la ville à la granja on le disait guy
parmelin est arrivé avec sa délégation
donc l'accueil et la photo officielle
le protocole d'accueil lui se fera à la
mai à la villa lagrange à quelques
kilomètres de notre position alors le
programme est bien les grandes lignes on
les connaît une donc le protocole
d'arriver à la fameuse poignée de main
tant attendu aux alentours de 13 heures
aux alentours de 13h ou ou peut-être un
peu après et puis une après-midi de
réunion on parle de quatre à cinq heures
de négociations quatre à cinq heures de
travail alors vladimir poutine et joe
biden et bien vraisemblablement ne
seront pas seuls ils ne se feront pas
face à face seuls ils y seront
accompagnés d'une délégation tout
d'abord une délégation restreinte côté
états unis ce sera anthony blinken le
chef de la diplomatie qui accompagnera
le président américain et puis côté
russe ce sera le ministre des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov avec qui lui
est arrivé hier soir il y aura également
une autre réunion de travail avec une
délégation un peu plus importante 1 par
exemple la délégation russe elle
comprend le vice ministre des affaires
étrangères ryabkov l'ambassadeur à
washington antonoff le conseiller du
président pour la politique étrangère où
chaque offre ou encore le chef
d'état-major gherasim off est ainsi que
le porte parole
peskov à l'issue de cet après midi de
travail pas de conférence de presse
commune c'était une volonté de la maison
blanche ce sera tout d'abord vladimir
poutine qui devrait prendre la parole en
fin de journée et puis joe biden lui est
bien conclure à ce sommet avec une
conférence de presse c'est ce qui en
tout cas est prévu mais au fil de
l'après-midi bien évidemment les choses
peuvent évoluer alors que l'on voit en
ce moment même à l'avion de vladimir
poutine atterrir à l'aéroport
international de genève je vous le
disais pas de protocole d'accueil a
priori sur le tarmac
il se fera directement à la villa à la
grange le lieu de la rencontre qui est
située à entre 5 et 10 km d'ici donc le
le transfert ne devrait pas être très
long et le programme donc qui a été
prévu les horaires devraient être
respectés les sujets abordés par les
chefs d'état et bien on les connaît
puisqu'ils ont été définis à l'avancé il
y aura notamment le dossier ukrainien il
y aura également la situation au
moyen-orient comme en syrie en libye ou
encore en irak et puis il y aura la
situation au karabagh autres situations
celle dans la péninsule coréenne est les
deux hommes qui devraient également
parlé de la sphère navalni un os elle
cristallise les tensions depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant et puis plus
récemment il y à la sphère biélorusse
les habiller l'hérault ici elle aussi
sous sanctions américaines comme comme
la russie est également sous sanctions
européennes donc tous ces sujets bien il
devrait être évoquée cet après midi on
peut penser aussi que les deux hommes
aient bien s'entretiennent sur le climat
c'est l'un des points où on peut trouver
des accords entre les deux puissances
alors que l'on voit l'avion du président
russe à l'instant qui devrait s'arrêter
d'ici quelques secondes maintenant il
vient d'arriver à l'aéroport de genève
alors qu'ils étaient convenus
c'est-à-dire à 12h30
ici en tout cas tout est bouclé un aux
alentours le trajet qui relie l'aéroport
à la ville à la grange et bien être
ultra sécurisé et là encore c'était un
défi pour la suisse pour vous donner une
idée
1 ce sont 2000 policiers de la police
cantonale de genève qui ont été
mobilisés ça représente 95% des
effectifs il ya également des militaires
au nombre de 1000 et qui ont qui sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui est justement ce
sont eux qui sécurise l'aéroport de
genève une base militaire d'ailleurs a
été a été monté un juste à côté de la
ville à la grange on sait également que
l'armée de l'air et mobilisés pour
surveiller l'espace aérien sur 50 km aux
alentours du lieu et 6000 mètres
d'altitude pour être précis et puis
enfin on sait aussi qu'un dispositif sol
air a été installé sur le territoire
alors un gros défi sécuritaire pour la
suisse gros dispositif a mis en place
pour cette journée on entend ici allez
les sirène retentira la proche de
l'arrivée de joe biden on voit son avion
en direct depuis genève qui va se
stationner afin que le président russe
vladimir poutine puisse descendre de
l'avion
on va peut-être en attendant la descente
du président russe allait faire un tour
du côté de la ville à la grange c'est le
coeur de cette rencontre le coeur de ce
sommet et alors on va on va rester en
direct sur ces images de vladimir
poutine qui devrait maintenant dans
quelques minutes descendre de l'avion
mais avant on va rejoindre la ville à la
grange vous le disais c'est le coeur de
cette rencontre où se trouve notre
envoyé spécial antoine claireaux et
antoine vous nous disiez il ya quelques
minutes la délégation suisse elle est
arrivée sur place
donc ils sont déjà
tout à fait ici c'est l'effervescence
véritablement on a vu tout à l'heure la
délégation suisse avec son président en
tête qui est arrivé il y à quoi 5 7
minutes et une partie de la délégation
russe qui elle est arrivée aux alentours
de midi il reste encore toute la
délégation américaine et puis bien
entendu les des prêts les deux
présidents qui devrait arriver
donc vous l'avez dit le temps que que
vladimir poutine rejoignent la villa
depuis l'aéroport
donc il prendra quelques minutes il sera
donc accueilli par le président de la
confédération suisse et dans la foulée
ce sera au tour de joe biden d'être
accueilli par son homologue suisse et
s'est par la suite véritablement que va
commencer
ces pourparlers entre les présidents des
deux puissances des deux grandes
puissances nucléaires mondiales
merci beaucoup antoine on vous retrouve
tout à l'heure pour suivre ce sommet au
plus près vous êtes à la villa lagrange
on le disait c'est le lieu de la
rencontre c'est le coeur aujourd'hui et
des échanges des échanges qui vont
débuter en début d'après-midi ils
devraient durer entre quatre et cinq
heures avant une prise de parole de
vladimir poutine pour une conférence de
presse suivie normalement par une prise
de parole de joe biden pas de conférence
de presse commune en tout cas une
volonté de l'administration américaine
alors que vous le voyez sur ces images
vladimir poutine qui devrait maintenant
descendre d'ici quelques minutes un de
son avion qui est arrivé à 12h30 comme
le programme est bien le prévoyait donc
pas de retards prévus sur l'agenda un
agenda qui va se poursuivre avec
l'arrivée de vladimir poutine ce sera le
premier à arriver à la ville à la grange
il sera accueilli par guy parmelin
le président suisse ensuite ce sera au
tour de joe biden d'arrivée et puis on
attend tous à cette poignée de main
protocolaire avant la rencontre de cet
après midi he les deux hommes je vous le
disais qu'ils ne se feront pas face à
face un ils seront accompagnés d'une
délégation la délégation restreinte
elle sera composée de américaine d'
anthony blinken le chef de la diplomatie
côté russe vladimir poutine sera
accompagné par son ministre des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov il y aura
également avec eux des traducteurs bien
évidemment pour faciliter les échanges
alors que l'on voit sur le tarmac les
véhicules de sécurité arriver pour
escorter le président russe vladimir
poutine qui va descendre d'ici quelques
minutes pour rejoindre ensuite la ville
à la grange je vous le disais genève est
une petite ville
donc les déplacements se font assez
rapidement au il devrait mettre entre 5
et 10 minutes pour rejoindre son
homologue suisse ce sera le premier à
arriver
et puis ensuite viendra joe biden qui
lui loge à l'hôtel intercontinental
tout autour tout est bouclé et là encore
pas de piétons pas de voiture c'est un
hôtel qui est situé à 5 minutes de
l'aéroport
là-bas de nombreux chefs d'état ont
l'habitude d'y séjourner et c'est là bas
que je vais y donne lui a choisi de
s'installer hier il est arrivé un vous
le savez dans le sillage de sa tournée
européenne avec la réunion des
dirigeants du g7
et puis de l'otan métaux mais
aujourd'hui c'est au tour de vladimir
poutine d'arriver à ce sommet il est un
peu plus de midi trente
l'avion présidentiel russe a atterri à
l'aéroport de genève si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france l'a
dit mir poutine qui devrait descendre de
son avion d'ici quelques instants
on voit tous ces véhicules sa garde
rapprochée l'attendre au pied de l'avion
pas de protocole d'accueil sur le tarmac
il se fera à la ville à la grange sur le
lieu de la rencontre à ou vladimir
poutine va rencontrer joe biden le
président russe qui est le premier à
arriver à la ville à la grange ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'il va croiser
voir en chair et en os son homologue
américain déjà en 2011
joe biden était vice-président de barack
obama et il s'était rendu au kremlin où
il s'était entretenu avec vladimir
poutine
mais depuis vous le savez joe biden est
entré à la maison blanche alors les deux
hommes se sont entretenus par téléphone
depuis janvier dernier mais c'est la
première rencontre le premier face à
face physique si je puis dire entre les
deux hommes
alors que le protocole de sécurité sur
le tarmac de l'aéroport de genève semble
être en place
le président russe ne devrait donc plus
tarder à descendre on est tôt plus près
on se rapproche du début de ce sommet
ici à genève entre vladimir poutine et
joe biden une rencontre dans un contexte
de fortes tensions
on le rappelle il n'ya plus
d'ambassadeur dans les ambassades
respectives des deux puissances alors là
encore ça pourrait être un sujet qui va
être abordée aujourd'hui ici à genève
cela pourrait être une conclusion de
cette rencontre en tout cas ça a été
évoqué notamment pour le kremlin
remettre des ambassadeurs à la fois à
washington et à moscou même si et bien
la russie ne s'attend pas à de décision
historique un pad percée diplomatique
pour reprendre les mots du ministre des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov il ya
quelques jours alors que l'on voit du
mouvement au niveau des escaliers de
l'avion vous le vivez en direct de sur
rt france de l'avion présidentiel russe
le président vladimir poutine qui d'une
seconde à l'autre maintenant devraient
descendre
pour une après-midi de négociation
chargé un de nombreux dossiers vont être
abordés vous le savez parmi les dossiers
d'ailleurs il a été en tout cas évoqués
il y a quelques jours dans une interview
du vladimir poutine un média américain
est bien la question d'un échange
éventuel de prisonniers entre moscou et
washington pourraient être aussi évoqué
un jour d'hui en tout cas le président
russe s'est dit ouvert à une la
possibilité d'un échange entre deux
américains emprisonnés en russie il
s'agit de paul couet lannes et trevor
raid
et puis il ya également des rues saint
qui sont détenus aux états unis
donc voilà ce sujet il pourrait être
abordé par les deux hommes cet
après-midi en plus un des sujets qui ont
été déjà décidée notamment le dossier
ukrainien on y sera très attentifs aux
déclarations qui seront faites ce soir
par les deux hommes les deux hommes qui
ne vont pas s'exprimer comme au tac au
tac comme nous le disions puisque pas de
conférence de presse commune prévue
c'était une volonté de l'administration
by donne alors un petit peu d'ambiance
ici à quelques centaines de mètres de la
villa lagrange et puis à quelques
kilomètres de l'aéroport de genève on se
trouve à entre les l'on va se trouver
sur le trajet de vladimir poutine
lorsqu'il va rejoindre le lieu de la
rencontre
et bien ici c'est un calme plat
pas une voiture pas un piéton aux
alentours si effectivement il ya eu le
ballet de sirène depuis ce matin est
bien là tout semble être en place pour
accueillir le président russe gros
important dispositif de sécurité
alors que vladimir poutine s'apprête à
descendre de son avion et bien on voit
ici sur le lac de genève de nombreuses
patrouilles en bateau un des zodiaques
de l'armée l'armée qui sécurise à la
fois l'aéroport aujourd'hui mais
également
le lac de genève on voit vladimir
poutine à l'instant vous le suivez en
direct sur rt france voilà le président
russe pose le pied sur le sol suisse
il va donc très vite rentré dans sa
voiture pas de protocole d'accueil sur
le tarmac qui je vous le disais ce sera
à la ville à la grange sur le lieu du
sommet que le président russe sera
accueilli par son homologue suisse
guy parmelin je vais y donnent les
rejoindra ensuite c'est donc vladimir
poutine qui arrive le premier
vous voyez une descente très rapide donc
un dispositif de sécurité important ici
tout est bouclé pour une arrivée rapide
à la ville à la grange je vous le dis
c'est pas très loin donc on peut
s'attendre à ce que vladimir poutine
arrive sur le lieu du sommet d'ici
quelques minutes seulement à moins que
il fasse vous pose mais visiblement ce
ne sera pas le cas donc voilà la voiture
présidentielle de l'adie mire poutine
qui quitte le tarmac de l'aéroport de
genève
on peut le lire de manière officielle
les deux hommes joe biden et vladimir
poutine sont désormais sur le sol suisse
le sommet américain et russe débute
aujourd'hui
un sommet très attendu c'est tout c'est
le monde entier dont qui a les yeux
rivés aujourd'hui sur la suisse doha une
journée une rencontre un sommet
exceptionnel que vous suivez également
depuis paris doha et vous êtes avec
votre invité un pour commenter cette
arrivée on vous le rappelle si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france
vladmir poutine vient d'atterrir à
l'instant à l'aéroport de genève
il est monté dans sa voiture et il va
rejoindre la ville à la grange là où les
discussions vont avoir lieu et le bal
des sirènes a repris à vous de raf
merci olivier allez on va continuer à
suivre ensemble en direct cette journée
historique et on décrypte on analyse un
petit peu ce sommet avec notre invité
qui nous a rejoint alain corvez ce
conseiller en stratégie internationale à
la corvette bonjour bonjour je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en direct sur rt france vous
êtes dans nos plateaux de caumartin joe
biden qui qui concluent donc son
opération séduction en europe avec cette
rencontre au sommet à genève
quel regard portez vous sur ce sommet
américano-russe tout d'abord je
reprendrai votre expression son opel
opération de séduction de baden en
europe il ya longtemps qu'elle était
entreprise par ses prédécesseurs et et
par son administration l'europe est
complètement séduite par les états unis
et nous sommes dans un atlantisme sans
défaut donc il n'y a pas d'opération
séduction il ya une opération de
resserrer les rangs pour faire face aux
menaces des etats-unis dans le monde
c'est-à-dire menace créée ou
décrétées par les états unis russie et
et chine alors concernant ce sommet on a
dit tous les dossiers qui fait qu'ils
allaient être abordées
mais les points de divergence sont
connus depuis longtemps et le les points
de convergence si on a relativement peu
sur le climat peut-être dit on et
pourquoi pas mais le en réalité je ne
pense pas qu'au cours de cet échange
entre les deux présidents américain et
russe
on va découvrir ddd possibilité de
négociations sur les points principaux
puisque le président byden est arrivé en
europe pour resserrer les liens de ses
alliés et en disant nous allons être de
plus en plus ferme vis-à-vis des ennemis
des etats-unis il n'a pas dit cela comme
ça bien sûr mais je traduis en termes
concrets nous allons être de plus en
plus ferme
nous occidentaux c'est à dire l'amérique
dirigeants ses alliés européens et vis à
vis des menaces que sont la chine et la
russie
alors le sommet est une bonne chose mais
déjà vous voyez le l'administration
américaine a refusé une conférence de
presse commune comme il y en a
habituellement après les sommets entre
chefs d'état sans doute que
une un certain malaise existe dans
l'administration américaine pour dire il
n'ya vraiment pas d'entendre possible
avec la russie je ne sais pas mais c'est
en tout cas c'est pas un bon signe que
l'administration américaine n'est pas
voulu d'un sommet en commun d'une
conférence de presse commune
on sait que joe biden voir en vous
admire poutine un adversaire redoutable
mais finalement lequel est le plus
redoutable des deux selon vous mais
écoutez il n'y a pas que les personnages
il ya les intérêts et il ya les nations
qui sont derrière byden et derrière
poutine et je ne pense pas qu'un autre
président russe mènerait une politique
très différente avec moins de fermeté ou
moins de 2 de dextérité mais en tout cas
les intérêts de la russie ils sont
connus et du côté américain c'est la
même chose
là il ya des différences plus importante
puisqu'on avait vu que tron
vous voulez prendre en compte le fait
que nous entrions d'un monde
multipolaire et qu'il fallait discuter
avec les partenaires étrangers et dans
partenaires il comprenait russie chine
et au tout en étant très ferme en
particulier vis-à-vis de la chine
mais aujourd'hui le
le sommet je pense de genève et
marc le caractère figé de cette
opposition fondamentale entre la
civilisation occidentale si tant est
qu'on puisse encore l'appeler de selon
la civilisation en tout cas de
l'alliance atlantique dirigée par les
etats-unis face au reste du monde
or le reste du monde et maintenant le la
partie la plus importante de la planète
mais trois quarts de la planète sont le
reste du monde l'occident n'est qu'un
petit quart de cette planète et le jeu
revient là dessus simple avait compris
et c'est pour ça qu'il voulait engager
des états unis dans une compréhension de
cette réalité qui est que la suprématie
américaine totale sur le monde est
terminée et qu'il fallait donc adapter
la diplomatie américaine et la stratégie
américaine d'une manière générale et la
défense américaine d'une manière
générale il y a une puissance nucléaire
très puissante très très grande qui est
la russie à la chine qui montrent
également dans le domaine de la défense
nucléaire et il ya d'autres pays la
suprématie américaine est maintenant
arrêter elle s'est manifestée pendant
dix ans à l'écroulement de l'urss
mais depuis déjà une dizaine d'années le
phénomène de multipolarisation du monde
ce ne fait que s'amplifier
alors il ya énormément de dossiers sur
lesquels les deux hommes n'arrivent pas
à s'entendre le plus brûlant si je puis
dire de ces dossiers et lequel selon
vous bon je pense que celle ukraine
et pourtant ce devrait que le dossier
qui pourrait s'il n'y avait pas s'il y
avait de la modération des deux côtés et
je pense qu'il y en a du côté russe et
qu'il n'y en a pas du côté américain sur
ce dossier on a vu comment s'est passée
la révolution de 2014 avec les services
secrets américains à la manoeuvre pour
renverser un gouvernement qui n'avaient
pas le plaisir de plaire à washington
donc le dossier ukrainien est un dossier
très sensible et pourtant cet instant un
dossier sur lequel ils pourraient
s'entendre
la russie n'a pas du tout intérêt à
faire la guerre à l'ukraine et n'a pas
du tout l'intention de s'emparer de
l'ukraine simplement ce qu'elle veut
c'est que les populations russophile et
russophone qui sont dans l'est de
l'ukraine soit considérée et et le droit
et à une certaine autonomie mais non pas
indépendance le le régime de
de la constitution ukrainienne et est un
régime fédéral mais qui doit être
accentué et permettre à aux provinces de
données de ces digues en ce que de
devenir
de d'avoir le droit de se gérer de la
façon dont il le chouette tout en
restant dans l'intégrité territoriale de
la russie de la de l'ukraine et bien sûr
la crimée est apparaît les russes pour
les russes définitivement et là on peut
pas on peut pas négocier là dessus mais
sur le donbass le pense qu'il ya des
négociations possibles car l'intérêt de
la russie c'est d'avoir une province
d'ukraine qui soit partie intégrante de
l'ukraine et qui dépendent de kiev mais
qu'il lui soit plutôt favorable et la
russie n'a aucune intention de s'emparer
de donbass
je pense que c'est ce que la dîmière
poutine pour a expliqué à baden si
toutefois bailon ne s'est pas déjà alors
joe biden qui a également déclaré après
son entretien avec avec ces années
notant qu'il allait signifier à vladimir
poutine
ces lignes rouges est-ce que vous pensez
que vladimir poutine pourrait également
voilà signifier lieu aussi quelques
lignes rouges à joe biden a écouté les
lignes rouges je pense que de part et
d'autre tout le monde les connaît
simplement parlé des droits de l'homme
concernant navalni et autres navale nick
est d'ailleurs un opposant qui
représente pas grand chose
en opposant politique qui représente pas
grand chose en russie
les lignes rouges je pense que des deux
côtés on les connaît parfaitement
mais je je je je ressens moi comme une
volonté du côté américain de ne pas
négocier de de rester un bloc atlantique
hostile à la russie et à la chine bien
sûr parce que en arrière plan il ya la
chine derrière tout ça alors que du côté
russe
et même du côté chinois également mais
du côté russe c'est très clair que la
diplomatie russe voulait mettre sur la
table les différents les différences
d'intérêt sur un certain nombre de
sujets mais négociée est trouvée parce
qu'il faut bien
à moins de faire la guerre il faut bien
trouver des terrains d'entente entre des
opinions différentes sur des sujets que
ce soit l'ukraine la syrie ou ailleurs à
cet égard d'ailleurs la syrie est un est
un point très important parce que
l'intervention russe de 2015 a
complètement transformé la situation est
aujourd'hui en syrie tout le monde
reconnaît que c'est la russie qui est le
principal décideur de la suite
alors voyez il ya des ya des points où
de part et d'autre on pourrait
s'entendre faire des avancées admettre
que l'autre a et est en position de
force sur tel à tel endroit ou sur tel
point et en tirer des conclusions mais
je sens en tout cas dans les
déclarations depuis que le président by
donne à débarquer en europe
la déclaration sont des déclarations a
priori hostile
en dix ans on vient pas pour négocier on
va définir des lignes rouges à la russie
il y a
une autre politique qui consisterait à
dire on va discuter avec l'art ici pour
voir comment on peut amener à baisser la
tension sur des points importants
l'ukraine l'afghanistan la russie
navalni ou autre merci beaucoup en tout
cas alain quand vs d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin en direct donc de nos
plateaux havre caumartin je rappelle
vous êtes conseiller en stratégie
internationale
on continue à décrypter cette journée
historique 1 avec nos invités en direct
bien évidemment nous avons des images de
genève en direct donc avec notamment
pouvoir présidentiel russe qui ne
devrait pas tarder à arriver à la ville
à la grange lieu qui accueille donc ce
faux mais entre vladimir poutine et joe
biden au poignet demain dans historique
dans quelques minutes
selon le protocole diplomatique mise en
place d' ailleurs nous irons en direct
rejoindre nos envoyés spéciaux
olivier de kairon flec mais également
antoine claireaux avant cela on va tout
de suite prendre la direction de moscou
se trouve notre invité xavier moreau
directeur de strates paul centre
d'analysé politico-stratégique bonjour
xavier moreau merci d'être en direct
avec nous depuis moscou alors rien ne
vaut un vrai bon face à face un pour
s'expliquer c'est en tout cas ce que
souhaitait joe biden en lançant cette
invitation à vladimir poutine
on y est à genève quel regard porte
justement les russes sur cet entretien
qui va avoir lieu dans quelques minutes
allez les russes en fait en dix ans les
élites russes allaient les commentateurs
n'attendent pas grand-chose de cette de
cette de cette rencontre
enfin cela dit c'est ce qu'ils disent
mais en fait ce que tout le monde
comprend bien c'est que c'est déjà une
victoire pour vladimir poutine puisque
joe biden qui était le vice-président de
barack obama à l'époque où justement
barack obama disait que la russie
n'était qu'une puissance régionale
or aujourd'hui la rencontre poutine
baril donnent ce sera sera le pour
l'instant le grand moment de politique
étrangère de 2021 alors à moins qu'on
ait une rencontre bach haydn les xi
jinping ce qui n'est pas exclu
c'est en fait donc en fait les états
unis ont été obligés de reconnaître que
la russie n'est pas cette puissance
négligeable qu'elle était devenue dans
les années 90 et même jusqu'au début des
années 2000 donc en ce sens cela déjà
pour les ruches cette perception est
clair c'est que la russie est au coeur
du jeu du grand jeu international la
russie dans le viseur des
des états unis on sait qu'on n'aura pas
les mêmes images que ce que l'on avait
pu voir lors du sommet d'helsinki à
l'époque c'était donald trump qui a
rencontré donc vladimir poutine pas de
conférence de presse commune aujourd'hui
est ce que la question une des questions
les plus sensibles au coeur de la
rencontre aujourd'hui sera également là
des informations en ligne les attaques
informatiques on sait que washington
accuse sans preuve
moscou d'être derrière des super
attaques
la russie a déjà proposé depuis
longtemps de coopérer sur la lutte
contre les cyber attaques mais je pense
que ce ne sera pas un sujet qui sera
particulièrement abordés par ce que joe
biden sait pertinemment que de la même
manière que les ingérences russe
supposée dans les élections américaines
sont sains sont une fake news pour
refaire un anglicisme et bien toutes ces
histoires de cyberattaques sont ne
servent qu'à maintenir une étape
tensions entre washington et moscou donc
je pense qu'on dira sur des sujets plus
concret d'ailleurs il suffit de voir la
délégation qui entoure vladimir poutine
vous avez lavrentiev qui est le
spécialiste de la syrie
donc pour les russes vous avez kozak qui
est le spécialiste de l'ukraine pour les
russes
vous avez guerre asimov qui est le chef
d'état major de l'armée russe c'est à
dire qu'on va parler des traités de
contrôler les armements va parler des
armes
l'hypersonique donc on va aller sur des
questions à mon avis très concrète et je
pense aussi que vous avez la présence
des deux ambassadeurs antonoff donc
ambassadeur de russie aux états unis et
sullivan ambassadeur des etats-unis à
moscou
on aura peut-être un accord sur la
reprise du fonctionnement normal du
travail des ambassades et des consulats
dans les deux pays puisque en 2017 un d
une représentation consulaire aux états
unis à san francisco avait été fermé par
la suite la russie a placé les
etats-unis en tant que pays hostile ce
qui fait que et ne peuvent plus employé
d'employés russes dans leur ambassade
donc les activités de l'ambassade et du
consulat américain en russie sont
extrêmement réduites donc mon avis on
parle de choses concrètes et
toutes ses excuses et moins encore pour
l'anglicisme et tout s'est fait que news
qui ont été utilisés pour pour faire
pression sur la russie à mon avis ne
seront même pas abordée tout le monde
sait très bien que c'est totalement
bidon alors xavier moreau je vous
propose de rejoindre tout de suite notre
envoyée spéciale à genève
olivier de kerentrech là olivier qui va
commenter pour nous l'arrivée du
président russe vladimir poutine vous le
voyez sur cette image
un dispositif de sécurité voilà le
le cortège donc des voitures dans les
rues de genève
au milieu la voiture du président russe
vladimir poutine qui va donc arriver à
la ville à la grange une bâtisse du
xviiie siècle qui se trouve au bord du
lac léman en plein centre de genève
notre envoyé spécial antoine cléroux
d'ailleurs est sur place il commentera
également pour nous cette rencontre
historique entre les deux chefs d'états
des deux plus grandes puissances du
monde
voilà plusieurs alors on va voilà vous
voyez donc la voiture du président russe
vladimir poutine qui vient juste de
passer à l'instant direction avila
lagrange où se trouve
antoine claireaux notre envoyé spécial
antoine le président russe vladimir
poutine va arriver dans quelques mittal
et non on va plutôt prendre notre envoyé
spécial olivier olivier d'autres car en
flex
oui oui effectivement doha alors le oui
effectivement doha alors le convoi de
vladimir poutine et bien arrive à
l'instant juste en dessous de notre
position d'ici dont je suis je le vois
arriver vous voyez nous on se trouve au
dessus de ce pont qui est en train
d'être franchie par le président russe
le président russe qui a donc atterri à
l'aéroport de genève a milli 30 comme le
prévoyait donc l'agenda et là vous le
voyez il va arriver sur ce pont qui va
leur permettre de rejoindre
de l'autre côté de la rive du lac de
genève la ville à la grange que vous
voyez actuellement à l'antenne
donc le président russe qui est le
premier à être accueilli par guy
parmelin son homologue suisse est donc
un gros dispositif de sécurité autour de
nous on voit dans les airs des
hélicoptères beaucoup d'embarcations
maritime militaire sur sur le lac de
genève pour sécurité ce pour sécuriser
ce qu'on voit ce qu'on voit vous le
disiez qui va arriver dans quelques
minutes maintenant à la ville à la
grange la ville à la grange la ville
halak
ange donc où se trouve notre envoyé
spécial antoine claireaux antoine
claireaux qui nous entend peut-être
qu'on va pouvoir peut-être rejoindre
pour qu'il nous dise un petit peu ce qui
se passe en ce moment donc antoine qu'on
va retrouver d'ici quelques instants
vous le disais le convoi du président
russe vladimir poutine qui est en train
de rejoindre le lieu de la rencontre
alors cette rencontre elle va durer
quatre à cinq heures cet après midi mais
avant il va y avoir la phase
protocolaire
c'est à dire cette fameuse poignée de
main notamment entre les deux hommes est
une photo en compagnie du président
suisse on sera bien évidemment
particulièrement attentifs à la posture
à l'attitude des deux hommes au moment
où ils vont se faire face ça fait dix
ans qu'ils ne se sont pas vu
physiquement puisque la dernière fois
c'était au kremlin et joe weiden lui et
paix alors vice-président de barack
obama
mais vous le savez depuis les choses
les choses ont changé le contexte est
différent avec des tensions croissantes
depuis l'arrivée de joe biden à la
maison blanche conscience croissante
avec son homologue russe on a notamment
a tous en tête ces mots en mars de joe
biden la dîmière poutine est un tueur
avait-il dit donc vous voyez ce n'est
pas a priori en tout cas la grande
amitié entre pour joe biden alors on
veut on voit en ce moment derrière les
arbres
le convoi de vladimir poutine arrivé à
la ville et à la grange le lieu de la
rencontre où se trouve
antoine claireaux notre envoyé spécial
qui est sur place qui va suivre pour
nous au plus près cette rencontre
antoine est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
quelle est l'atmosphère en ce moment la
ville à la grange alors que le président
russe s'apprête à arriver sur place
oui tout à fait c'est même en ce moment
que le convoi arrive est déjà 3 4
plusieurs voitures et j'aperçois juste
qui prenne le virage à côté de moi deux
limousines les limousines aux russes se
sont les limousines du président de
marque aux russes du marque 100%
fabriqués en russie on voit également la
sécurité les portes ouvertes près
intervenir donc c'est un convoi de d'une
douzaine de véhicules qui passent à à
l'instant même
sachant que la délégation russe elle est
arrivée en deux fois entre 12h et 12h30
d'abord avec dimitri peskov puis ensuite
avec sergueï lavrov qui qui est arrivé
donc vers 12h30 on voit les premières
portes s'ouvrir les premiers dignitaires
qui est voilà poutine on voit la poignée
de main
hélas eux
le président suisse échange quelques
mots avec vladimir poutine
sur le perron de la villa lagrange
et l'invite à entrer à l'intérieur
poignée de main pour les photographes
et voilà très rapidement poutine adressé
un signe de la main aux caméras ainsi
qu'aux photographes qui se trouvait
juste devant le perron de cette ville à
la grange et maintenant le reste de
l'escort va pouvoir avancer et se garer
un peu plus loin sur les parkings prévus
à cet effet
[Musique]
ouais
il
alors effet si vous nous rejoignez sur
rt france est bien le président russe
vladimir poutine vient d'entrer à
l'instant dans la ville à la grange le
lieu de la rencontre de ce sommet entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden il vient
d'être il a été accueilli par guy
parmelin c'est son homologue suisse la
suisse qui se réjouit d'ailleurs de
cette rencontre
le monde a les yeux rivés vers genève
aujourd'hui ce sont un peu plus de 600
journalistes qui sont accrédités 1 pour
poursuivre ce sommet
donc c'est joe biden maintenant qui est
attendu et qui sera accueilli par guy
parmelin après l'arrivée à l'instant
vous avez pu le suivre en direct sur rt
france du président russe vladimir
poutine
une session photo 1 est prévue à 13h25
dans quelques minutes donc une photo
avec les trois hommes dans dix minutes
avant une rencontre bilatérale entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine alors le
protocole prévoit normalement un bref
mot un des chefs d'état au moment de
leur arrivée
alors on verra si ce sera le cas dans
quelques instants en tout cas maintenant
vous voyez un les suisses qui attendent
et bien le coup voix de joe biden à
présent joe biden qui va partir de
l'hôtel intercontinental où il
séjournait il est arrivé hier en vous le
rappelle vous voyez un sur ce pont sur
le lac de genève
beaucoup de badauds un qui était présent
d'ailleurs il ya quelques minutes
lorsque le convoi de voix de vladimir
poutine a rejoint la ville à la grange
genève où les drapeaux russe et
américain flotte dans les airs notamment
le long du pont la dîmière poutine en ce
moment même alors qu'on voit ces images
de genève et tentera de s'entretenir
avec guy parmelin on attend maintenant à
la ville à la grange l'arrivée de joe
biden pour le début de cette rencontre
de ce sommet entre les chefs des deux
puissances doha vous suivez également
pour nous depuis paris ce sommet en
compagnie de vos invités et on va
continuer à décrypter
voilà ces images historiques et cette
rencontre que tout le monde
attentes ou calais le monde entier est
sur le qui vive on voit donc
l'effervescence à genève même nous
sommes toujours en direct avec xavier
moreau directeur de strates paul centre
d'analystes politico stratégiques alors
on le disait je pense que pour l'as pour
vous aujourd'hui en tout cas et pour
tout le temps il pour john joe biden on
ne peut plus on ne peut pas ignorer le
poids de la russie
cette grande puissance mondiale un
contact tête à tête était très important
tout cas pour le président des états
unis
d'ailleurs dubaï donne a expliqué
récemment qu'il souhaitait une relation
stable et prévisible avec la russie où
il est possible de travailler ensemble
est ce que le domaine de l'armement
c'est un voilà un des points sur lequel
les deux hommes pourraient avoir une
convergence de vue tout à fait
d'ailleurs comme je le disais si le
général guère asimov le chef d'état
major de l'armée russe est là c'est bien
pour parler de ça c'est il ya plusieurs
tamiya la prolongation ddd des accords
internationaux sur le contrôle des
armements
il y as pourquoi pas remettre en place
le système de survol des territoires
communs aux russes et aux et aux
américains donc tout ça tout ça qui est
tout c'est toutes ces organisations dont
voulait sortir donald trump et bien il
est possible que joe biden y revenir et
il faut dire aussi une chose c'est que
pour joe biden la situation sera
beaucoup plus facile paradoxalement que
pour donald trump parce qu'il est clair
qu'il y avait entre vladimir poutine
donald trump une entente
du point de vue on va dire relations
humaines mais une fois rentré à
washington donald trump était pieds
poings liés par le congrès américain
puisque le congrès américain
systématiquement proposer des sanctions
les voter et comme plus des deux tiers
des votants était favorable à ces
sanctions donald trump et être tenus de
les appliquer ou enfin il était beaucoup
plus difficile pour lui de 2 de
continuer dans sa dans sa voie de
rapprochement avec moscou
or joe biden lui n'a pas cette
difficulté puisque on va bien on ne va
bien sûr pas l'accuser d'être d'être pro
russe
même si d'ailleurs vous avez des
sénateurs républicains co peut-être cruz
et même si donald trump d'ailleurs a dit
que le dr poutine allait à les manipuler
joe biden qui n'était qui n'était pas
taillé globalement si joe biden prend
des décisions en matière de politique
internationale
ce sera beaucoup plus facile pour lui de
les faire de les faire adopter par par
le congrès américain
donc comme les états unis encore une
fois sont demandeurs de cette rencontre
eh bien je pense qu'il y à il ya moyen
d'avancer sur sur certains sujets et où
il faut aussi noter que les russes en
fabriquant désormais de série toute une
gamme d'armes hypersonique que les
américains n'ont pas et n'auront pas
avant cinq ou dix ans les ce sont les
russes en fait qui dans ce domaine la
mène le jeu est d'ailleurs déjà à
l'époque donald trump dans l'est dans le
cadre des négociations sur les armements
je voulais faire rentrer les armes
hypersonique dans ce domaine donc il y à
il ya de quoi faire et je pense que je
pense que on peut avancer sur trois
sujets il faut pas il faut pas partir
totalement
tout le monde l'a dit qu'en fait on
n'avancerait pas que c'était un premier
contact mais parce que bien personne ne
veut être ne veut être déçu et surtout
il faut bien se rendre compte que joe
biden vis-à-vis de ses élites démocrate
vis-à-vis de son électorat doit avoir
dans l'est dans les déclarations
publiques une position extrêmement
hostile à la russie et à vladimir
poutine c'est pour ça qu'il a parlé
ligne rouge etc etc
mais les russes ne sont pas stupides
j'admire stupide manière plus tine n'est
pas stupide ainsi que ça gagne lavrov
et ils savent très bien que les chefs
d'état occidentaux que ce soit jo by day
nous mêmes et emmanuel macron disent une
chose pour leurs opinions publiques et
en font une autre au moment des
discussions qui de toutes manières
resteront secrètes pour ce qu'elles
auront de vraiment important
alors j'aimerais que l'on revienne
anticiper sur leurs rapports de force
entre ces deux grandes puissances et le
timing précisément de cette rencontre
entre joe biden et vladimir poutine on
sait que joe biden vient d'achever une
tournée européenne la première tournée
depuis son investiture à la maison
blanche il a rencontré les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement du g 7 ses alliés de
l'otan
est ce que justement cela lui permet
d'arriver en position de force
à genève je dirais oui non parce que oui
il a rencontré ses alliés de l'otan il a
rencontré angela merkel mais angela
merkel a obtenu des états unis qu'elle
que les avis ne sanctionne pas nord
stream 2 ni d'ailleurs le directeur
général de l'ins crime de qui est un
citoyen allemand
donc en fait à mon avis une des
démarches aussi de joe biden va être de
sauver la face puisque la politique
américaine qui a été suivie tant par
donald trump que par joe biden par les
républicains les démocrates a échoué
pour empêcher la construction de nord
stream 2 donc il va falloir que joe
biden trouve le moyen de sauver la face
vis-à-vis de cela donc à mon avis on
aura une déclaration de l'admirent
poutine qui va dire que oui nous sommes
prêts à maintenir un certain volume de
transfert de transit de gaz par
l'ukraine
de toute manière la russie à l'intention
de faire et c'est dans son intérêt de le
faire il faut pas se priver d'avoir un
système de transit comme celui de
l'ukraine
donc il y aura toujours un minimum de
gaz qui passera
mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas non
plus oui effectivement il a rencontré
ses alliés mais il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui l'allemagne qui est le
grand pays d'europe occidentale qui et
je dirai l'interlocuteur quasi unique en
europe de la russie et bien a obtenu ce
qu'elle voulait et a fait passer ses
intérêts économiques et énergétiques
avant avant l'alliance atlantique avant
la cette fameuse solidarité atlantique
qui kiné n'est pas en si bonne position
que ça en tout cas dans le domaine
énergétique
merci beaucoup en tout cas xavier moreau
d'avoir été en direct avec nous depuis
moscou je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur du centre d'analysé
politico-stratégique on va tout de suite
prendre la direction de genève retrouver
notre envoyé spécial olivier de kerran
plec car à présent à l'écran vous pouvez
voir le convoi présidentiel de joe biden
[Musique]
joe biden qui passa à quelques mètres
derrière nous maintenant vous le voyez
en direct sur ces images alors il fait
route vers la ville à la grange
rejoindre et bien son homologue russe
pour le début de ce sommet ici à genève
en ce moment même
vladimir poutine lui est en train de
s'entretenir avec guy parmelin le
président suisse on l'a vu il ya
quelques minutes
rentré à l'intérieur de la villa
lagrange et c'est au tour maintenant de
joe biden est bien de se rendre sur le
lieu de la rencontre le président
américain qui est à genève depuis hier
il est arrivé aux alentours de 16h15
dans la foulée dans la foulée de sa
visite européenne vous l'évoquiez avec
votre invité doha joe biden était au
royaume uni pour la réunion avec les
dirigeants du g7 du g7 puis à bruxelles
pour une réunion avec les dirigeants de
l'otan joe biden d'ailleurs on l'a
entendu qui a appelé à consolider ses
alliances notamment avec les européens
pour faire face à la russie mais aussi à
la chine
donc effectivement joe biden dans un
état d'esprit assez offensif en tout cas
au niveau diplomatique
comme on peut le comprendre après ses
dernières déclarations il s'est affiché
en quelque sorte comme le porte parole
des droits de l'homme
à en croire une interview donnée il y a
quelques jours un média américain alors
vous le voyez en direct si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france le convoi de joe
biden qui arrive à la ville à la grange
et qui passait bien juste en dessous de
notre position alors un convoi
impressionnant avec des motards en tête
de ce convoi
pour encadrer la voiture présidentielle
américaine
le président américain qui va arriver
maintenant
dans quelques minutes à la ville à la
grange
ici un dispositif de sécurité
particulièrement important alors
l'avantagé ici à genève c'est que les
distances sont assez courtes donc les
transferts se font assez facilement vous
l'avez vu un
une dizaine de minutes alors on va les
voir ils arrivent ils vont arriver dans
quelques instants on les voit un la
ville à la grange la ville à la grange
où se trouve notre envoyé spécial
antoine claireaux qui est sur place
alors antoine racontez-nous vous voyez
le convoi de joe biden arrivé à présent
oui tout à fait je le vois qui arrive au
loin et le dispositif sécuritaire est
vraiment très impressionnant derrière
moi il ya des policiers qui se tiennent
debout tous les to les 5,7 m et là on
j'aperçois la première voiture d'escort
qui arrive au niveau qui va arriver
d'ici quelques instants niveau du perron
de cette ville à la grange est derrière
une dizaines de berlines noires qui font
leur chemin jusqu'au perron alors les
voitures de lettres portant
on n'entend plus aux petites gens tant
plu liaison avec notre envoyée spéciale
à genève
antoine claireaux vous le voyez sur ces
images nous sommes donc en direct de la
ville à la grange le lieu qui va donc
accueillir ce sommet entre vladimir
poutine et joe biden vadimir poutine qui
est déjà l'intérieur en compagnie du
président suisse et dans quelques
instants
ces jobs hayden qui va sortir de la
voiture présidentielle américaine john
madden donc est arrivé hier à genève
mais qui vient d'arriver
le deuxième donc à franchir le seuil de
cette ville à la grange
voilà le président suisse pardon qui est
donc à l'attendre après avoir attendu
vladimir poutine pour une poignée de
main sous l'oeil des journalistes qui
sont présents olivier de 48 me disais
nous le disait qu'il y avait environ
plus de 600 journalistes accrédités pour
cet événement historique
un sommet entre les deux plus grands
chefs d'état des grandes nations la
russie et les etats unis l'invitation
rappelez-vous va été lancés par jobs
hayden joe biden qui vient d'achever
donc sa tournée diplomatique en europe
l'a notamment mené au royaume uni au à
bruxelles et puis à lincent la voilà
avec le président suisse
joe biden qui va donc lui aussi à faire
cette photo protocolaire cette poignée
de main entre les deux chefs d'état et
puis le président américain va
rencontrer son homologue russe vladimir
poutine des discussions charger un
programme chargé
plus de quatre à avoir six heures de
discussions entre les deux hommes on
sait que le dossier brûlant sont
nombreux lors de cette rencontre une
rencontre pas vraiment voilà en tête à
tête puisque les deux ministres des
affaires étrangères des pays respectifs
donc la russie et les etats-unis seront
également présents autour de vladimir
poutine et joe biden allez on va tout de
suite retrouvé notre envoyé spécial
olivier de kerran flec
oui doha alors on a pu suivre avec vous
un cette poignée de main entre guy
parmelin au président suisse et joe
biden alors et gagner avec se sont déjà
rencontrés puisque le président suisse
avait accueilli avait accueilli joe
biden à son arrivée à 16h15 hier à
l'aéroport international de genève donc
deuxième poignée de main si je puis dire
entre les deux hommes qui viennent de
rentrer donc à l'intérieur de la ville à
la grange où joe biden lui est arrivé le
premier après un atterrissage vous avez
pu le suivre en direct sur rt france à
12h30
alors maintenant on attend bien
évidemment et bien la poignée de main à
la photo entre vladimir poutine et joe
biden et bien cette session photo en
présence également du président suisse
elle est prévue à 13h25 donc dans cinq
minutes
peut-être le temps que joe biden
échanges en privé avec le président
suisse on voit ici
cette ville à la grange où cet
après-midi les réunions de travail
auront lieu quatre cinq heures de
réunion
selon l'agenda indiqué alors pas de
conférence de presse commune
on voulait dit depuis ce matin prévue à
l'issue de cette rencontre entre les
présidents américain et suisse c'est une
volonté de l'administration américaine
alors les observateurs soulignent qu'en
2018 à elin ce qui est bien la
conférence de presse entre donald trump
et vladimir poutine avait tourné en
faveur du président russe en rentrant
aux états unis donald trump s'était vu
reprocher sa faiblesse notamment alors
peut-être que c'est effectivement une
explication pour comprendre pourquoi les
deux hommes ne s'exprimeront pas
ensemble ce soir
en tout cas on attend d'ici quelques
instants
cette photo cette image cette poignée de
main entre vladimir poutine et joe biden
les deux hommes qui se connaissent un
ils se sont déjà rencontrés c'était il
ya dix ans
mais c'était au kremlin cette fois et
joe biden n'était pas locataire de la
maison blanche mais il était
vice-président de barack obama
à l'époque le contexte était tout autre
là on le sait il ya des tensions
croissantes depuis l'arrivée de joe
biden à washington alors les sujets on
en connaît une bonne partie des sujets
qui vont être abordés il y aura
notamment l'ukraine dossier épineux
il y aura également la situation au
karabagh ou encore dans la péninsule
nord-coréenne la situation au
moyen-orient devraient être également
être évoqué un la syrie la libye l'irak
notamment la sphère navalni aussi qui
cristallise les tensions depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant est prévue au
sujet des discussions et puis la
biélorussie antoine claireaux notre
envoyé spécial est sur place les deux
hommes sont sur par lyon rejoint
immédiatement antoine gayraud en direct
de la ville à la grange antoine c'est
tabou
[Musique]
oui tout à fait donc vous l'avez suivi
en direct joe biden est bien arrivé à la
suite de vladimir poutine est en ce
moment même c'est tout le convoi qui qui
va trouver sa place vers les parkings
prévus
c'était d'ailleurs assez impressionnante
joe biden est arrivé en premier suivie
d'une vingtaine de véhicules d'où sont
sortis tout doux est sortie toute la
délégation américaine en même temps et
qui ont rejoint le les salles qui leur
sont qui leur ont été attribués en effet
c'est assez spécifique cette ville à
cette ville à la grange
elle a un plan symétrique et ainsi
chacune des délégations à exactement
même le nombre de salles est le même
même la même surface au centimètre près
qui leur a été accordée afin que
personne ne se sente lésé d'une façon ou
d'une autre
[Musique]
merci antoine alors on voit à l'écran
guy parmelin s'exprimer entouré à sa
droite du président russe vladimir
poutine à sa gauche joe biden le
président américain
[Musique]
la première photo officielle du sociaux
mais ici à genève entre wladimir
klitschko le protocole au début de cette
rencontre en direct sur rtl
[Musique]
une tente en vain
donc le début du protocole pour cette
rencontre tant attendue entre le chef
des deux puissances russe et américaine
accueillis par guy parmelin qui a quitté
le perron de la villa lagrange la
poignée de main tant attendu entre les
deux hommes vladimir poutine joe biden
pour les caméras et les deux hommes qui
rentre pour débuter leur session de
travail quatre à cinq heures de réunion
maintenant de négociation sur divers
sujets comme la situation en ukraine on
le disait où la question de sécurité de
l'armement également alors les deux
hommes voilà sont rentrés ils devraient
être rejoints par leurs délégations
puisque alors à priori pas de tête à
tête a prévu un là encore ça peut
changer mais en tout cas il est prévu
que l'un et l'autre soit accompagnée
côté américain se sera anthony blinken
le chef de la diplomatie américaine côté
russe le ministre des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov qui lui doit
accompagner son président pour le début
des réunions de travail qui vont durer
quatre à cinq heures en direct sur rt
france le début de cette rencontre entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden en direct
de la ville à la grange à genève à une
rencontre à un sommet qu'on suit
également en direct depuis paris avec
vous d'oreille avec vos invités
si olivier pour toutes ces précisions
aller les portes de la ville à la grange
se sont donc refermée avec un
l'intérieur le président russe vladimir
poutine et joe biden président américain
des retrouvailles sous le signe de la
défiance pour en parler nous sommes en
direct avec jean pierre guéno historiens
bonjour jean pierre guéno merci d'être
rendue
avec nous vous trouvez donc dans nos
studios de caumartin alors on sait qu'il
n'ya pas vraiment de projet vise et on
va dire de reconfiguration des relations
en tout cas en configuration radicale
des relations entre moscou et washington
on sait que barack obama mais aussi
george bush avait tenté justement de
mettre à plat leurs relations qui était
attendu est ce qu'aujourd'hui il s'agit
seulement de poser on va dire les bases
d'une nouvelle relation froide mais
pragmatique
oui on devrait retrouver des relations
diplomatiques plus fluide souvent les
apparences dans un contexte dont vous ne
cessez de rappeler qu'il est qu'il est
très jeune lourd et est chargé de nuages
alors c'est intéressant ce qu'on vient
de voir parce que la poignée de main
aura duré deux secondes
elle n'a pas la force la durée de la
poignée de mains de 1985 cet état à
genève
c'était le choc reagan gorbatchev on
était à 6 ans delà de la fin de l'urss
et on célébrait d'une certaine façon le
dégel c'était la grande conférence du
dégel à cette époque la poignée de main
reagan gorbatchev avait duré sept
secondes
alors il nous faut revenir en arrière il
ya trois autres face à face entre les
américains et les russes qu'il est
important de resituer par rapport à ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui
d'abord 1943 c'est la conférence de
téhéran
et elle est importante cette conférence
puisque les trois grands staline
roosevelt churchill se retrouver
entérine le principe d'une démembrement
de l'allemagne du partage de l'europe
et puis va entériner le projet de
débarquement en normandie pour juin 44
qui peut oublier une autre conférence
qui est celle de yalta en 45 qui est
également très importante
à nouveau on retrouve à face à face
entre roosevelt et staline et cette
conférence va avoir beaucoup
d'importance pour l'avenir pour le
déplacement des frontières entre la
pologne et la russie pour l'évolution
des relations mais j'ai l'idée de
d'évoquer une route un autre face à face
c'est peut-être le fou rire le plus
tragique de l'histoire
on est en 95 on n'est pas à genève
comment 85 ha on est à new york et en 85
qu'il y à un face à face entre mobile
clinton et mauricette sli et en fin de
compte il vient d'y avoir un constat
d'échec en réalité c'est à dire qu'il
faut mettre en place une force de paix
on est un mois après la fin de la guerre
de bosnie herzégovine et il va y avoir
une boutade de maurice helsinn je cite
je suis plus optimiste
repartant ici que lorsque je suis arrivé
dit il après mon discours dié vous
annonciez que ma rencontre avec bill
clinton serait un désastre c'est vous
les journalistes qui est l'un des aphtes
et alors cette île chambre la presse
alors que les deux hommes viennent
d'aboutir à un semi échec puisqu'il
n'arrive pas à se mettre d'accord pour
positionner la russie dans la force de
paix qui va se mettre en place
hélas cette boutade qui chambrent
l'apref va déclencher un des plus
terribles le fou rire d'eux
les l'histoire de ces relations ont
nourri tous encore parce qu'on a oublié
tout ce que je viens d il faut quand
même rappeler que ça se situe un mois
après la fin de la guerre aux bonnes
moeurs et gavin hier qui a fait cent
mille morts qui a déclenché
l'afflux de réfugiés de deux ou trois
millions de réfugiés viols collectifs
massacre c'est quelque chose
d'absolument épouvantable c'est ce fou
rire est bon on n'est pas du tout dans
le même contexte les relations sont plus
tendues il n'y aura pas de fous rires
cette fois ci c'est fou rire il faut
rappeler notre fou rire quand hitler
gesticuler dans les années 30 on ne
prenait pas au sérieux et ses
gesticulations déclenchait une certaine
hilarité comme comme en 95 pour ce que
je viens de citer
on peut se demander si cette réaction
des opinions publiques qu'elles soient
suscité par le déni ou par la peur ne
sont pas en fait
la crainte la peur d'ouvrir la boîte de
pandore et de regarder en face les
situations géopolitiques internationales
voilà justement est ce que en tant
qu'historien vous pensez que finalement
aujourd'hui l'histoire est un éternel
recommencement vous parliez justement de
ces entretiens en 1943 45 et puis entre
boris elstine et et bill clinton il y
avait à l'époque une guerre froide qui
étaient ouvertes déclarée entre ces deux
puissances entre l'urss à l'époque et
les etats unis aujourd'hui
voilà on sent que il y a comme un air de
déjà vu entre elles la russie les états
unis
oui en même temps c'est très différent
il s'agit on s'achemine vers une autre
forme de guerre froide plus technique
plus virtuel on voit les procès
d'intention ou les où les accusations
qui sont portées de part et d'autre on
sait ce qui s'est passé avec des hackers
russes dans les campagnes électorales
américaine on sait qu'aujourd'hui vous
le rappeliez tout à l'heure le contexte
qui fait que eux
joe biden viennent se rapprocher de
l'europe et de l'otan donc à cet égard
la russie est un peu isolé et puis le
vrai problème actuellement de dans
l'immédiat la véritable urgence de joe
biden il peut pas se battre sur tous les
fronts à la fois c'est à la fois
d'essayer d'en terminer avec le co vide
et puis c'est surtout la chine qui est
qui qui paraît beaucoup plus
préoccupante ces lacs sur ses priorités
donc il faut pas attendre de miracle de
ce face à face dans quelques heures mais
simplement le retour à une certaine
normalisation des relations
on n'est plus du tout au stade où on
était avec donald trump l'imprévisible
inénarrable l'ingérable donald trump
on est là dans quelque chose qui devrait
se normaliser davantage
merci beaucoup en tout cas jean pierre
guéno d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
vous êtes historien voilà on a fait un
petit peu un petit rappel 1 sur ces
sommet russo américain on assiste
actuellement à une journée historique
puisque c'est la première rencontre le
premier face à face officielle en tout
cas depuis que joe biden a été investi à
la maison blanche avec vladimir poutine
les deux hommes sont actuellement à
l'intérieur de la villa lagrange
accompagné par saga lavrov le ministre
des affaires étrangères russe ainsi que
le secrétaire aux affaires étrangères
anthony blinken côté américain nous
allons continuer bien évidemment notre
couverture spéciale tout au long de la
journée pour cet événement historique
rendez vous à 14 heures avec grigoriy
petitjean mais également nous envoyés
spéciaux à genève au lit les deux quarts
en flex et antoine avec l'hérault
très bonne journée à tous sur arte
france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois de
films stratégies peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
[Musique]
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
monsieur l'ex chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
gallo chose dont j'ai commencé à faire
des vidéos pour youtube dans ce qu'on
appelle un blog beauté maintenant je me
maquille je rentre des produits
cosmétiques
j'en parle et beaucoup de gens ont
détesté ça allait beaucoup d'invités sa
touche pas il ya cet homme juste pour le
fait d'exister
nous prenons un peu de crème
anticellulite la première fois que je
fais face à des agressions